[Music]
black holes are among the most
fascinating objects in our universe
and also the most mysterious
[Music]
a black hole is a region in space where
the force of gravity is so strong not
even light the fastest known entity in
our universe can escape
the boundary of a black hole is called
the event horizon a point of no return
beyond which we truly cannot see
when something crosses the event horizon
it collapses into the black hole's
singularity an infinitely small
infinitely dense point where space time
and the laws of physics no longer apply
scientists have theorized several
different types of black holes with
stellar and supermassive black holes
being the most common
stellar black holes form when massive
stars die and collapse
they're roughly 10 to 20 times the mass
of our sun and scattered throughout the
universe
there could be millions of these stellar
black holes in the milky way alone
supermassive black holes are giants by
comparison
measuring millions even billions of
times more massive than our sun
scientists can only guess how they form
but we do know they exist at the center
of just about every large galaxy
including our own
sagittarius a the supermassive black
hole at the center of the milky way has
a mass of roughly 4 million suns and has
a diameter about the distance between
the earth and our sun
because black holes are invisible the
only way for scientists to detect and
study them is to observe their effect on
nearby matter
this includes accretion disks a disk of
particles that form when gases and dust
fall toward a black hole and quasars
jets of particles that blast out of
supermassive black holes
black holes remained largely unknown
until the 20th century
in 1916 using einstein's general theory
of relativity a german physicist named
carl schwartz child calculated that any
mass could become a black hole if it
were compressed tightly enough
but it wasn't until 1971 when theory
became reality
astronomers studying the constellation
cygnus discovered the first black hole
an untold number of black holes are
scattered throughout the universe
constantly warping space and time
altering entire galaxies and endlessly
inspiring both scientists and our
collective imagination
[Music]
you